[Musique]
souhaitait pas je déroule mes rêves
mange doucement car tu marches sur mes
rêves bien que moi qui travaille à la
maison on vient d'avoir notre petit
deuxième je crois qu'il est temps qu'on
augmente
je ne veux pas augmenté autant augmenter
un drogué mon enfant est une drogue si
je comprends bien toléré tu es viré
évidemment non mais c'est mccrary au
wahoo désirer elle revient elle revient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui es tu je suis molly la nouvelle
hauteur parce que oui je sais la chaise
de mendel ça tu peux t'asseoir s'il te
plaît d'accord je vais utiliser sa
seconde était très très clair dans la
très confortable cette poubelle nul
doute chaise c'est la base de notre
émission je suis venu te dire que cette
année sera ta dernière croit ils ne
pourront pas être remplacés
si tout le monde tu adores
je sais ce que tout le monde pense de
moi j'ai peut-être eu la chance de
décrocher ce boulot mais je suis pas
assez bête pour le perdre
qu'est ce qui cloche avec moi
précisément tu es un peu trop blanche et
un peu trop vieille qu'est ce que je
peux y faire
j'ai un truc pour le monologue pas j'ai
pas besoin de prendre l'accent anglais
un nom c'est ton démission l'expression
de qui tu es
comment décririez-vous molly elle a dit
que j'étais une éclatante taches de
couleur sur les toffes grise et uniforme
des notre équipe c'était énorme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai besoin de toi molly j'ai besoin de
ta façon de t'imposer et de ton absence
de limites semaine
non je n'ai pas tissage non non pas avec
ces mots là mais tu ne nies avec ses
mots ni avec d'autres
[Musique]